no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no you know that's a writer's job is to
voice things that people can't say
nobody says anything
unless they want something he says what
what brought you to Casablanca and
Bogart says the waters and God Reign
says it's a desert and poker says
something like I was mistaken I was
misinformed I was missing before which
is great dialogue just great dialogue
music it's music you know which is the
difference between
like we're doing here and an interesting
dialogue an interesting dialogue first
thing you have to understand about
dialogue is that it's got to be
connected to the character's desire line
in the scene in other words if a
character has an objective an intention
in the scene the dialogue has to match
that intention and what I see a lot of
times especially with Exposition and
information is that a character is
saying
all that information and you can tell
that it's really The Writer's objective
in other words the writer wants to wants
the audience to know this information
because they think okay the audience
needs to know this and this and this and
this so the character is going to say
this in this business and that doesn't
work because scenes and dialogue are
about a character's intention in a scene
everything a character says
is matched to what that desire line is
to know your character's goals and their
wants
uh in general and then also in that
particular scene so then that will
inform how they speak you know if they
want this out of that other character
they would talk in this way you know
because they're trying to maybe sway the
other character
ideally the audience is in on that too
it knows their wants that was something
that David Mamet always said he said the
only thing an actor needs to know is
what they want in the scene and ideally
the audience knows that too when you
reread the dialogue
ask yourself for every line why is that
character saying this why is that
character seeing that specific line most
of the time it will be because they're
responding to what so they're reacting
to something that's fine but a lot of
the times you will find that a character
is saying something because you want the
character to say that not because the
character wants something in that scene
at that specific time
so you've got to know what the character
wants and then every line of dialogue is
a strategy for that character to get
what they want and if that dialogue is
not that then you rewrite the line until
it fits that what are they trying to
achieve in that scene what's in the way
and sort of what are they doing to try
to get through whatever's in the way
that's pretty much the template for
pretty much every scene so then it's
like okay part of that is going to be
dialogue part of that is going to be
what they say and what they say should
be
the the things that they would
believably say given who they are and
what their unique voice and way of
speaking is in that situation given
what's going on and what they want when
you go to say something there's probably
a hundred different ways you could think
of to say it why are you choosing the
particular way you you choose and when
you start to think like that
um and why your character is choosing to
say something that way and what they
really don't want to reveal like why why
will they go to this length but they
won't go just a little bit more
vulnerable when you kind of understand
that about your character then I think
writing the dialogue becomes easier but
you have to put that thought process
into it first to know what they want to
conceal and what they want to to give in
an ideal world it's more often than not
it's subtextual
so that what's being communicated is
really more about what's underneath the
words than the words themselves
it's also dialogue is also the words
that aren't spoken Sometimes the best
dialogue is what's not said people also
don't always just express everything
they want right the best dialogue has
subtext which means the audience can
pick up that they're thinking and
feeling something they're not saying
but what they're saying is what they
think is the right thing to say to try
to like get whatever it is that they
want or the the only thing that they're
sort of able to say for whatever reason
given who they are and what's going on
but it's helpful if there's this sense
of subtext of we know what the inner
life is underneath that that they're not
saying I think it's more useful to think
of subtext as the underlying verb
what am I doing
what am I doing in the scene an actor is
asked what am I doing and dialogue is
action with words that's all it is it's
somebody doing something but they're
using words instead of actions physical
actions and so it's a useful thing when
you have a scene that's already written
to just see whether you can reduce each
line of dialogue to a verb
and the kind of verbs you're looking for
are things like attack defend deflect
persuade seduce those are the kinds of
verbs you want the lines to have okay
you don't want explain
it's just emotionally neutral and that's
where the Q a thing comes in so
if you have a dialogue how are you today
and the person says well I didn't sleep
much last night that's q a but if you
have a character who says you look like
hell and they say well I didn't sleep
much last night you see now you've got
attack defense hey I didn't sleep much
so you transform it into something
that's actually moves that actually is
uh Dynamic and we're following action
each scene is pushing your story forward
so that means each scene has a goal like
a little mini goal of the larger goal if
you don't know what that is you can get
lost in the sauce of your dialogue and
your action right if you're writing
features features are pushed more by
action than dialogue that doesn't mean
that I need to literally see more lines
of action but it may mean that there are
more opportunities to remove dialogue
because action can tell me
um what it is that they could have said
so like I said before how can you show
me that you're angry without telling me
that you're angry right so instead of
cursing mom out I'm going to slam the
door and walk out right so now you got a
line of action instead of dialogue what
I call Q a dialogue how are you today
okay how about you well not bad I think
I'll go to the store what about you I
think I'll not go to the store what
that's that's q a dialogue a lot of
times the people are sitting and talking
right you're in a room you're in a house
or whatever and so they're sitting and
talking but I think making sure that
that pacing is good
um so it just doesn't feel like really
you know people just explaining things
that's kind of the death of people's
dialogue is when people over explain and
they don't know how to sort of weave in
that that Exposition kind of nicely
um then it really just kind of like
hangs there that's
that's not good writing on the nose
dialogue is
dialogue that is generic
it is describing something that we could
easily see
that is clear in the scene
it's explaining something
um it's just kind of like lazy dialogue
that doesn't
uh show that character's voice on the
nose dialogue usually means your
characters are saying everything that
they're thinking there is no Nuance
there is no subtext let's say you have
two lovers and they're at a table and
it's beautiful and you know candlelit
and one says to the other darling I love
you I love you I love you and he says
well that's not actable because it's
it's too on the nose this is what on the
North dialogue the only thing about
drama in any form
is what actions are playable what and
they're not playable so what I've
learned in the course of my writing life
and of watching other people's work is
is
crying the woman cries that's not a
playable you have to be more descriptive
about it what is she doing when she's
crying that the actor's always going to
find something else to do something
better but you got to give them a hint
they have talk but no dialogue
talk
human speech can be poetic it can be
witty clever
moving but it isn't dialogue unless
there's there's action
under it it's conversation with a
purpose
it's it's people conversing
but every line
needs to move the story forward in some
respect whether it's moving the plot
forward through some sort of Revelation
that a character makes
or
moves these characters forward in their
own relationship because they have an
argument and that conflict causes one or
both of them or more of them to shift in
terms of their thought processes and
feelings
or it provides some exposition
some information some data which is a
key to help them get a clue to move the
thing forward
but yeah dialogue
is conversation but it's conversation
with a purpose you need to be really
mindful of that the other thing to keep
in mind about a screenplay as opposed to
a novel is it's a limited amount of time
so it has to be richer every they say a
novel is drama a novel is Gossip drama
is Scandal yeah everybody is instead of
walking you're running so if you have
dialogue it's precious and you want it
to be rich in uh Pulp Fiction there's a
moment where Bruce Willis character goes
to buy some cigarettes and he says to
the bartender he says
one pack of red apples
and the bartender says filters and he
says None and that's just a really cool
fast interesting exchange there as
opposed to five lines to explain what
brand of cigarettes he wants and oh you
know what how about no filters in those
cigarettes you know because it's very
noirish feel it's very
um you know clipped and dark and tight
and it's just filters none and that just
gets the the idea across my issues I
write too much dialogue like my first
film was like they just said look man
this is a 10 page scene there's talking
and I'm like well I don't know how to
cut it because I love everything they're
saying and I'm like that's what they say
he's like well we can cut it now we cut
it in the editing room the problem I see
is when it's too long you know then
we're kind of Wonder okay where's
where's the conflict where is what's
happening here I mean it might be
interesting but but you know even
something that's really interesting for
too long will disengage an audience
after a while
so don't you could do it just don't do
it for too long especially for new
writers you don't want to have super
super long dialogue blocks and too many
monologues
um
just saw Oppenheimer and Christopher
Nolan has a lot of expositional and
explanatory dialogue but it makes sense
because they're all scientists and
they're going back and forth about all
of these scientific topics and they're
just giving detail after detail
and it's you you are okay with it more
because visually he's a stunning
director you know the big screen
experience is important to him and I saw
it in a theater and it is interesting to
watch
but on the page I'm guessing
there's just it would just be so much
long long long Dialogue on the nose
dialogue scenes with so much Exposition
and I'd be like oh my god when are they
going to stop talking about fission
versus Fusion you know so a newer writer
who doesn't have that track record who
isn't known for something like Aaron
Sorkin might be known for monologues but
you're not so you really want to
um keep the dialogue as tight as
possible maybe with the
you know a few flourishes every now and
then maybe you do have a key monologue
um once or twice in your script that uh
ideally it captures theme it explores
the theme what your story is about read
your dialogue aloud yes very good point
well that that's not coming off my
tongue very easily I don't think I want
to ask somebody to say that you know
when composers compose and you're
writing for an orchestra and you don't
know how to play the French horn and you
can't play the oboe and quite often
after it's done you have people play
through the parts and they say that's
unplayable you can't finger it that way
and they have to go back and they have
to change their parts because they're
not writing for that instrument I had an
absolute
crash course in writing dialogue years
ago I used to write with Charlie Sheen
um I don't care if they don't credit him
and the sitcoms he's been in as a writer
I know who's been writing the dialogue I
worked with him for three years I I
never read or heard better dialogue from
anybody than that came from him that he
wrote and I asked him one day I used to
be really good at writing scene
Direction my dialogue was flat it wasn't
interesting it wasn't engaging it wasn't
edgier seat
and I asked him one day when we were
writing
um the way we worked is we'd set it up
and I would write the scene Direction
and he would do the dialogue unless you
know it was some basic stuff it was easy
and I finally said to him I said where
do you
get this
Encyclopedia of incredible dialogue I've
never heard anybody with it before and
he said you just listen
he said you know when this was working
these aren't working and if these aren't
working you can't absorb what's
happening and how people interact and
find those gems he said most most of the
things that I write that people like I
heard at a party I heard at a barbecue I
heard at an airport I heard while I was
pumping gas he said you know I'll get
out and pump gas and I'll hear a couple
bickering in the car next to me at the
pump
and he said that's gold he goes that is
gold man he said you know and this is
before everybody had phones we weren't
listening to them we were doing this so
I find the best the best advice to
writing a dialogue is listen in
listening to how real people talk it
doesn't mean you're transcribing it
exactly you know people don't talk like
they're in a movie but so there is a
certain amount of you know dramatic
license that you have to use but you can
write two cinematically you know you can
write two theatrically into too much
like your characters are on stage and
that can come through on the page and
that can really hurt your script problem
is a lot of people try to outwit
themselves with dialogue they think they
got to use verbiage or words that people
don't use they got to show you how smart
they are I think we've talked about it
before it's like the drummer that
overplays everything to show look how
good my chops are and it's not about
that it's it's about
it's about making things sound organic
and that's a lot of things that the
actors have to understand too is you
know they're acting or are they truly
listening and responding with the work
there can be dialogue that's too poetic
right like it's so poetic that we aren't
really having a conversation anymore and
we aren't really pushing the story
forward anymore we're just saying nice
flowery things one of the mistakes a lot
of screenwriters make is that they all
the all the characters sound exactly
alike you should be able to you know
block out the character name and know
who's talking I like to talk a lot about
contrast so you have two characters in
the scene it's really always more
interesting if if the characters are
contrasted so if a character is speaking
in a formal way so somebody who's an
academic or a professor or a doctor and
he speaks in a formal way make sure that
the person that he's interacting with
speaks in a more slangy way or you know
more contracted way because that's going
to make you're going to create that
contrast you know just like in painting
if you you want to highlight color blue
you surround it with yellow right it's
opposite so it's the same thing with
characters a lot of the techniques in in
the dialogue chapter in the book are
about individuality how do you create
individual voices because having all the
characters sound the same is a very
common problem with dialogue It's
usually the writer's voice does this
line belong to this character or or is
it someone else that has to say that
should say that line and the easiest one
is irony
you take a character
um who says you look like hell okay
that's a straightforward attack it says
you look beautiful just flip it
completely upside down and they'll be
like what do you mean I couldn't sleep
last night you know they'll defend
themselves because they're going to get
it because a lot of human interaction is
ironic speaking of dialogue this is a
total aside but it's just the funny
thing that happens to a South African in
La it's really funny is this um so I was
surfing and this guy was surfing his
board he fell off his board and he's
bored with I picked his board up and I
gave it to him I was on the shore and I
said something like oh I see your board
has got space for two fins which is
anyway which is a strange sentence you
wouldn't normally say but I could see
his face and his face was like this
human being is talking to me I think
he's talking to me in English it's
definitely English and he's confident in
English
but it's not American and then I said it
again and then he was like okay he is
speaking English and he is very
confident I need to like adjust my brain
to understand what he's saying and then
I spoke it again and then he was like he
understood me but it's really funny to
see that happen here it's just it's
total aside but it's in terms of
dialogue you know like the the
miscommunication that can happen with
dialogue is really funny and then the
subtleties the subtext man it's just I
find it really funny because like
English is my home language this is the
way I speak but when I speak at you
every time I see this look on people's
face it's classic it's the like this man
is not from America and he's talking to
me I've never spoken to South African
before I don't know what the space is
it's really a great look anyway I'm sure
Trevor no understands luckily for Trevor
Noah thank goodness for Trevor now he's
opened up the door to South African
accents yeah right